niché au quartier guesdon au
saint-esprit la piscine communautaire de
l'espace sud à trouver ses marques
800 nageur venant de tout horizon chaque
semaine et le samedi matin c'est pour
les tout petits vins bien l'ag et chez
toi j'ai créé à missira lombard
aujourd'hui il pleut un peu et il fait
froid il faut donc être stratégique avec
les enfants prenez ces dames entre nous
dans l'eau qu'ils ne sont pas dans l'eau
pourrait qu'il n'ait pas froid
ce bassin et les chauffer donc ça va un
peu mieux aujourd'hui c'était ses
délibérations et de l'automobile
donc la croyance exercice là c'est
beaucoup de bien sur son visage aux bras
ses jambes 5 à 6 mètres
oui son autonomie donc 68-61 de votre
oreille s'approprier le milieu aquatique
s amuser le tout sous l'oeil des parents
certains d'entre eux profitent du moment
pour nager eux aussi tacle week-end on
profite pour à déposer mathilde à son
cours de natation et on allie l'utile à
l'agréable et on en profite également
pour patauger à côté pendant qu'elle
fait son coin quelques mètres plus loin
dans le même bassin des membres cette
fois-ci de l'association rêves des
coulisses qui barbotent dans l'eau et à
les écouter c'est que du bonheur
cette piscine on l'a pas fait pour un
rien deux fois profiter et ça fait du
bien quand on arrive à un certain âge
toute façon ça fait du bien aux
articulations ça fait du bien par tous
je suis venu mon dieu ma phishing ça
nous fait du bien ça n'aura jamais y est
a dans le sien quand alors black tie and
dye bien remplie
opérationnel depuis juin 2018 la piscine
accueille des particuliers des
associations et des scolaires
en dépit du modèle économique et
peut-être respectifs a kiss in
communautaire de l'agglomération de
l'espace sud
à gestion privée donc les élèves que ce
soit à l'école publique proulx l'école
privée ils doivent payer pour venir à la
piscine les enfants sont contents de
venir à bessines donc on peut pas leur
courrier de donner un avis et nous
anticipons autres fréquentation de la
piscine des professionnels du
paramédical comme des kinés ou des sages
femmes
autrement dit la structure a touché un
public vraiment très large